step on up in come on in his where the
fun begins there's so much to do do
really just for you you they singing
reaching you Disney Afternoon hey those
were not the words but I don't give a
shit you turn because we're singing all
about the diggin Disney Afternoon
you remember more lyrics from Hank I
don't card there now if you done Rescue
Rangers ever know did you did you
fantails rescue a ticket to Japan did
awareness danger know though it never
fails
see I love Italy I could just see the
guys again guys where's your poison
whose don't eat it all songs are just so
fucking into it I mean they're just like
it sounds like they're putting their all
into it no you are staying man this is a
magical adventure I want to be like you
know the Gateway to heaven the most joy
tours you can
oh so delicious gummy bears oh those
singers I but if they were all done I
like the same group for some oh yay
to spin a wheel tail spin Rintoul a
thinketh like the whole thing is just
gonna be a singing the songs nothing
else um now we're gonna be talking about
the Disney Afternoon uh a video that
does I guess not surprisingly well but
I'm really happy it does well I didn't
think it'd do because the Disney
Afternoon was amazing ah it's yeah at a
point I you know looking back more and
more as much as I love a lot of shows
who grew up with us so many of them
we're not good
I'm just looking at I can I'm seeing the
commercial value now and the selling the
toys and stuff like that and Disney
Afternoon I think was just at the cusp
would like Tiny Toons was coming out and
then Fox Kids was starting to get put
together and Disney have two new what's
kind of their before them so I I do
almost feel like this was cast a garden
that history is strange as it sounds
because it's fucking Disney if they
didn't feel like they were meant to sell
toys yeah
that's the we're I mean the thing about
that Disney product did not feel like it
was invented just to sell toys but it's
true I every one of those shows at least
up until some of the later ones I didn't
feel like oh yeah this is a shield to
sell some toys they were creative
they were inventive and god damn it what
was up with the Mighty Ducks we know if
that gets into what I think holds up so
well about is that they really we can
still watch them now yeah you know
they're for little kids but they're
still very creative and very very
innocent just always say the word
innocent and timeless they're timeless
shows up until a certain point they were
not about trying to be hip or all up in
your face with like pop culture it would
it was very pretty lad in that way yeah
we like Aladdin good don't get me wrong
but that the movie but there is yeah
there is that double-edged sort of like
as funny as a land is that kind of
kick-started that oh like oh you'd save
a bunch of in jokes for the adults
yeah let's make kind of pop culture and
like well Aladdin did it well like the
cartoon shows that came in after that
like 92 93 cat like started to slide
slowly Robin Williams there and he just
had this comic genius doing all this
stuff and you get you get to animate
Robin Williams that's just amazing woman
but in transition from like the kind of
late 80s aesthetic into the 90s where it
was like just tell an entertaining story
and that slowly gave way to to the
extreme and it's like oh god that sucks
you know even actually even the Robin
Williams thing though did you ever see I
think was like the third Aladdin movie
was like for VHS or whatever they got
him back to know it I said I've seen the
whole paper I saw a little bit that is
clearly like they did say stop when they
do this stop or they just kept going
good
we got him let's do everything we can
with them it's like in the first movie
it kind of went a little far vets like
was it really soft at the lens of big
screen
no that I didn't see it's just and I'm
okay with that but yeah and that was it
a case where it's like wow there was
like three or four scenes you could have
easily caught with Rob
ways or at least got them down but
anyway yeah just in the afternoon this
is the hand spell one of my favorite
reviews that we did my one thing I got
to watch all of the Disney Afternoon
shit yeah it actually was like at first
was really good and then it slowly
became a dear God turn it off kept going
on but again kind of started with gue
triple I don't dislike gue true uh but
it kind of starts there yeah cuz then
we're taking out we're taking out the
imagination and the different worlds and
everything were just suburbia I never
hated goof troop because that would have
required an emotional investment in goof
troop I never even had to begin with um
but I was so apathetic to goof troop so
just didn't care like hating goof troop
would mean that it was so all but it
wasn't even that it was just all of the
shows up do you have like you meant
gummy you have really if we're going way
back and like the Wuzzles in the 80s
then gummy bears then you add ducktales
Rescue Rangers tailspin the idea was
take these classic characters and put
them in like this really cool setting or
something that was kind of out there it
was creative and inventive like the the
Rescue Rangers was kind of like a cross
between the littles and stuff from the
Flintstones Reds take ordinary devices
and like build like an airship or
balloon out of it and they're
capitalizing elfs are a timeless idea
and goof troop was the first one where
I'm like wow this is um really not very
imaginative like it's like alright we're
gonna have goofy he's gonna have a kid
and they're gonna be living in the
suburbs high jinks like that was in and
and their neighbors gonna be peed and oh
it'll get wacky and like it that was in
like really this after all of these
shows like good like some domestic
suburban drama like I'm not even drama
but some domestic like suburban do fake
it serious yeah he's going against his
name tag max I've been diagnosed with
cancer
yes I got me think of goofy without what
is that what an interesting um but don't
get going to what you were saying about
the aloof dig I got it the only thing
I'll say in defensive goof troop is it
was mostly harmless well and that
doesn't stop a piece family you have to
admit is great Pete's family is what
made that show work it certainly was a
max um well as Pete's son's name was a
PJ yeah I'm not even gonna say was PJ
masks PJ and goofy himself I thought
were the most boring characters pH P K's
life and pistol though now PJ in the
molarity with the family is fun okay
that's emeritus creative his father and
everyone it's just he's a John Doe not
so much but yeah when whatever Pete
enters the picture it's it's
legitimately really funny yeah um but
the rest of it some of the delivery from
the actors who did max you know watching
it again it could be funny you know
she's a comedic actress and she's was
yeah comedian actors and yeah it said
training with like you know Jenny Jason
and Jason yeah sugars Andre Liam
um National Lampoon and she's hilarious
isn't that so some of her deliveries are
very very funny uh but the character
itself it's just not written that great
ya know heard it's not an acting problem
it's just a writing problem none of the
writing on the show outside of whatever
problems Pete has in his domestic
situation was it was never that funny
but it giveth this much at least it was
not sucked into the whole extreme thing
like it was the beginning of that yeah
so it was still way more toned down than
like later bullshit like you're still
taking quag pack and duster trying to
meet up funny like hey an adult can
watch this and still like it yeah half
and stuff like that just not as good
it's not it's not time or so you still
look at that and go late like I could
put on tail spin and duck tails and
Rescue Rangers is timeless and gummy
bears II he was like yeah yeah Darkwing
Duck unless you knew animation that well
and knew the timeline
you wouldn't guess what it was made but
gooftroop I can already start to feel
I'm like this is nightmarish you see but
still not as obnoxiously so is the later
when the later ones back over here Oh um
but yeah you know you're talking about
the sewing your favorite reviews to film
uh really mine to stepping into is
setting up that room a little was so
much fun I had so much junk food uh and
when you start this or eat that junk
food and you're surrounded with it like
it is like you just sort of start to go
into time cancel like wow I really am
kind of back in the 90s here this is a
little surreal uh alright we just get
home from school crack open those Little
Debbie oatmeal pies and go to town yes
that as a total sweetheart hostile eyes
uh stone what else we roll up thing too
haha dare the fruit snacks for roll up
so yeah you like cuz they have the
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtle fruits
oh my case you're all over that yeah
that wasn't first I was just Turtles
anything turtles as well not to me there
was nothing but those Little Debbie
oatmeal cookie those are but we did and
then minutes I always you go on the
offers house to get those cuz they
always have a ton and then I like yeah a
whole box good idea to appetite Oh
amazing but uh we're talking intended to
go damn um yes it's all it is perfect
yeah yeah so like what it would be the
way to goodies Early 90s for us yeah I
get so much of it is kinda like the
experience I really want to recreate
that I think that's why people relate to
it so much is because they really do
remember the posters and we just had a
lot of those posters still we have
amantha studio and yeah I think people
sort of remember this day a lot of
snacks are still around but it's like I
can't find those specific ones that
we're back even even back then uh yeah
and I think I think that's why you know
you got stuff like whatever like Pokemon
and Ninja Turtles and stuff that was fun
as a huge part of your childhood but
it's you know clearly dated I think
that's why Disney Afternoon does hold
such a strong place in people's hearts
because you can still watch it even
though it's it's clearly for kids I mean
don't get me wrong it's not quite like
Batman or Anna
Wow I could still watch this like as an
adult I like it even more by more
respect for the Disney ones because they
did show such restraint and I wasn't
about it don't joke it didn't feel like
a cheap corporate shill like you know I
mean as much as I find Turtles hilarious
still a rigid E it's like we gotta sell
some toys yeah we don't when you know
where's this one they had the characters
first it's like okay we have these
properties how do we come up with an
interesting show that kids will want to
watch like dad did that felt like that
was their number one goal first and
that's the way it should be yeah not not
to say the toys and everything aren't
they clearly oh yeah and not to say that
you can't have an entertaining show that
was meant to sell toys I mean I liked
the original Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles but there is something kind of
special about when you feel like the
writers were taking extra care to come
up with something really interesting and
to be fair to Turtles I think they were
trying that to know like okay how are we
gonna be born and they were comic
writers and stuff like that but you
fucking gummy bears they made a cartoon
out of the candy and it was surprisingly
really creative and fun they all had to
sing guys well how would you just want
to be there just sitting at Disney
Studios and I just worry I still watch
it my kids like to eat gummy bears make
a show now but here's like a sister what
do you do with that and if they somehow
coughed up something that was pretty
decent if you hear some buzzing by the
way that gardeners out there so sorry
nothing dumb but uh yeah you sort of
have like this is why whenever
somebody's like oh you can't do anything
with the idea you can't it's just a dead
idea and stuff it's like oh yeah you can
but there are some are more difficult
than others but yeah I think a lot of
that limitation can really really help
you because it's like one one hand you
have to make a show about the gummy
bears this candy it if there's no story
behind it or anything on the other hand
you can do whatever you want and that's
sort of what's great about it uh you
know a fucking Richard Williams did this
uh Raggedy Ann movie when nobody did
anything a Raggedy Ann and it I'm sure
it's not at all what people expects it
when they do that again
it's like he's just like I'm gonna do
whatever I want that he saw the
potential he just made something totally
batshit crazy uh I don't know if it's
good but it's definitely worth checking
out it's a total dread they were
creative they were timeless they took
her audience pretty seriously
like gummy bears head it's medieval
setting uh DuckTales was like fucking
Indiana Jones that first story arc was
amazing yeah well it was the first that
was one of the few cartoons we saw from
the beginning because we saw when it
premiered and we were watching that
whole story arc unfold and you know that
whole first two hours of the show you
know when they're trying to find the
lost city of gold or whatever was really
legitimately like interesting if you
were like an 8 year old at the time well
I think with Disney one of the things
that Disney really has I mean just like
80% of the time uh whether it be it
shows or movies or whatever is that has
atmosphere and it has a feel and it has
an environment and every single one of
those shows I Rescue Rangers Darkwing
Duck tailspin and duck tales they all
have their unique kind of feel to them
they all have like have their own unique
environment you know that dark we dunk
obviously is kind of like you know a
funny Batman and so forth but that's
crossed with the shadow though it's like
a myth yeah that's my life direction it
was a mixture of everything because it
was there was very much this uh there
was a Batman feel to it like the his
sort of duck plane or whatever in the
city the city was vaguely Gotham s but
but the outfit is actually more than a
shadow it's got the cape he's got the
hat you know what even the villains are
kind of combination of like the marble
on the DC yeah even kind of radial I
mean they had an obvious Joker there but
some of them look like something out of
a Marvel comic instead and you know what
was his name the which one oh um the
jester guy Oh quack reject microjet okay
so uh we and the fight thing is watching
them again I got I actually bought the
DVD of dark McDuck after as much as
emphasizing Elly you know what the show
actually want the show and watch it
again there's definitely like don't get
me wrong there's definitely like awkward
moments where it's like okay this is
kind of like early 90
these kids show we're not perfected yet
we came right anyways you see my name is
for a promoter like that and it's still
people trying to see what can they get
away with in kitchen nowadays and thank
God
kid shows are amazing right now they
really really are and add me from what I
see it anyway I mean so many are taking
them so much more serious basically was
Disney's version of like the tick like
if you cross the tick with like Batman
may not say that like but it was not as
like the tick I think skewed in an age
group a little higher but it had that
same quality of like making fun of
superhero as well so yeah telling
superhero story and I think that time
you know like I said of like a dark
McDuck and Batman x-men Animaniacs and
stuff and Titans of stuff they are all
experimenting to seeing what they could
get away with in kid shows in terms of
how how much effort are we allowed to
put in because there was such a push in
the 80s just to sell the toys uh you
know just get about as quickly as
possible so there was kind of this
thought of how how much can we sort of
play and make this smarter to make this
interesting and do whatever we want but
also make it kind of kid-friendly and
today the experimentation has gone so
much further on to where they're really
really playing with so many different
ideas like I said with a venture time
Steven universe gravity falls I mean
this just it's some real golden age
right now uh but you see where it kind
of started I think it is sort of start
around with kind of Disney Afternoon and
fox kids and stuff and you can see we're
kind of dying later than that yeah we
had a Vinny somes
yeah uh and it did go dead for a while I
guess I can't act like you know I'm a
huge connoisseur room kids entertainment
when it's y-you like when he kind of has
died started dying is when Cartoon
Network started picking up the slack and
you had Nickelodeon starting to get into
it a little bit like I feel like there
was something about the whole Disney
Afternoon thing going down the toilet
that that's when you started seeing
things like Samurai Jack and stuff crop
up and you know so it it is you're right
let's move elsewhere but I felt like the
disney side have been definitely in a
period of time where it's just like air
yeah well you know and the kids it see
as the kids grow up and then they're not
interested in the shows and then you'll
probably have like you know this sort of
valley of nothing that good coming out
cuz when I'll in mind now we have to
find what the next generation is gonna
like what the next big thing is going to
be my ducks won't be timeless systematic
Peck you know by me that didn't pokemons
pick up kind of after the Disney
Afternoon died it's like okay now
everything's Annamayya and we start
getting into digimon pokemon they start
getting all these cows in I don't that I
don't think kids entertainment died as a
whole but every and you know you there
are people who studied the history of
Nickelodeon who will tell you what the
peaks and valleys of Nickelodeon were
and same thing with Cartoon Network and
I feel like that with Mighty Ducks in
quag pack that was a valley yeah Verdell
like that was like we are exhausted
we're out of ideas how can we just try
to appear to be hit and that's the thing
whenever Disney tries to be hip
if soap and edit they suck so hard and
trying to be hip like that and like I
just remember seeing the ad once for
quack back and I'm like no I'm like no I
wouldn't have like the only reason I
ended up watching any of it is because
we had to review it and even that was
just pain I think we saw cuz it Amer
that's when I can't remember this like
the death of like a little bit of my
childhood I don't mean that like a bad
way it was more like growing up or
whatever by Mary we moved to Rhode
Island and I think I was starting like
eighth grade or ninth grade or something
like that and like the cartoons were
coming on hey Disney Afternoon I kind of
like Disney Afternoon whatever and there
was quack pack a mighty dogs let's try
to cling to what little of my chat out
his left head and in bonkers was still
on and stuff and I kind of watch it I'm
like you know I was like bonkers was
least yeah dumb cat watch it's like no
one wasn't that bad or just kind of man
I was kind of a myself but I think I'm
done with cartoons you know and I was
kind of when the Superman Batman thing
was happening that was a little in
Batman Beyond which weren't bad but they
weren't as good and it was one of those
things where I served mistook it for I
think I'm just growing up and this is
kid stuff now when really I think it
it's kind of true we were growing up so
much people were watching it but I think
it also means less effort and money
being put in as well and now they're
trying to find the next thing which was
you know Pokemon or whatever so but
again I mean now we're doing being logs
on kid shows today cuz their trucks that
much harder and they are trying so hard
to get the audience the older audience
in there which they're seeing the the
profit and the importance of it so
they're trying so much harder and yeah
kids movies
nowadays are you know yeah we got like
Marvel and stuff but really like
original ideas I mean it's like it was
something but Kung Fu Panda and inside
out and stuff maybe that's kind of and
the thing that they go
it's a closest thing we have to like
original anything about Adventure Time
and Steven universe and a lot of these
shows is we'll be able to look back and
to some degree like we'll be able to
look back look at the animation sound me
like okay 80s Early 90s Disney Afternoon
but there is a timelessness I think
that's gonna last with these shows and
would be love them or hate them whether
they really last throughout the decades
you're not going to look at it and go so
2012 let me tell you like it it just is
exist in its own kind of world where
it's like now we're only how many years
after crack back like what 15 but you
look at something like but like I could
look at something like rescue rangers
and um ducktales and stuff like Huey
doing Louie and ducktales there is
nothing about them like fuck that is
so 1990s so 1989 or winter I just like
that is just so oh like no because they
just kept the characters timeless
whereas you look at something like wet
pad and it's it's embarrassing
it is Emily embarrassing the watch it's
just like who greenlit this who thought
like yeah this is gonna be hip like it
the funny thing is quack pack at least
for me was dated like on arrival it was
do a dictated on around because I was
like it I like automatically I'm like
wow this is already four years behind
what the 90s are supposed to be about
like on its release and so now it's just
even way worse there can be a charm to
that don't get Fresh Prince of bel-air
is so obviously dated but it's so to
much better show but yeah it's
so it is I hate to use this word extreme
in how wrapped up in its time period it
is that it does priya kind of is very
charming likeable time capsule and it
did just go so far where something like
quack panic just felt like it was only
trying to hit the demographic in jersey
things argue this in a strange way there
is more of a timeless innocence to Fresh
Prince of bel-air but I have been there
everything today we're trying to be bad
characters that way make it wide hack is
too fucking cynical for its own good you
can see literally the dude going
according to the chart he should wear
his head backwards and he should have
sunglasses and then they should all go
you know Will Smith and all those people
willing to show you know they grew up in
that environment they did wear those
clothes and he was a rapper before then
and he actually any other day didn't it
just didn't feel is obvious like they
hit it better um and with with Mighty
Ducks and quack back in those shows like
hey yeah all your good money Doug says I
think that's the better show than quack
back like cuz it's just it's a stupid
sci-fi plot and it's ridiculous but I'm
like this is along create yeah it's a
little more creative but just fucking
hey quack ah sorry that's my rant I'll
go talk about something positive no it's
fun because I kind of remember when they
came out and I was like like I said al
Qaeda al cartoons anyway but there was
this parmi that felt kind of insulted
and bad because I'm like you know they
our kids really do kind of deserve
better than this they deserve better and
they deserve these timeless stories and
effort deserve what we got kind of and I
was not feeling bad cuz that was also
kind of during the Dark Age of films
where we're getting like Godzilla
battlefield heroes and an Robin and I
was kind of it was a very kind cynical
time I really was like this Universal
Valley until about like Lord of the
Rings and Harry Potter
yeah perhaps back at home and I was
getting kind of cynical better team
because I love movies and I love
entertainment I love what they can do
and I was feeling kind of bad cuz I'm
like wow people are not doing what they
could be doing and I was a big game
gamma point where I'm like well is this
ever
to come back or we hit the high point
it's now I know it's just part of a
course there's always gonna be pits and
valleys and everything you look at the
history of film and TV and radio and
stuff it's all like that there's always
points where they sell out run out of
ideas and then but something else comes
up eventually it just might take a few
years
um but yeah but but it's also fun seeing
how we got to that point I think stuff
like the Disney Afternoon played a big
part cause people did remember those
stories and we're inspired by him and
said let's try this
between the Disney Afternoon and the WB
stuff the the Batman 105 the thing you
should call like the Fox kid Sofia yeah
the Fox kid stuff but I mean it was WB
purdue's um that's why I was saying the
the stuff that Fox was running between
Disney Afternoon and stuff Fox was
running like Animaniacs Tiny Toons
Batman I really I think the influence
still extends to this day like really
what they paved what the creative teams
behind that did we're still feeling the
after-effects of it mostly I think in a
good way yeah so even though I've hit
that drop-off you know near the end like
the way animation completely dominates
now and the high quality we forget this
like I you know we are the 80s was so
perfect it was so great like when I
watch all these cartoons I'm like they
look pretty bad huh I'm like this is not
aged well at all like I like it for
nostalgic sake but I'm like really when
I want high quality animation I really
do have to look at like what they were
doing on Disney in the 90s and the same
thing with Fox and like that's where
they really kicked it up another notch
because otherwise the 80s are just
they're not too far removed from old
hanna-barbera tricks people know every
time there is a cheapness to it and you
know it's just fun in its own way
there's a grittiness to it but at the
same time I'm like yeah like we trade it
up you know in the 90s when it came to
animation you know what I feel what I
think I think a lot of it is that so you
got these shows like iTunes and
ready Rangers and Batman Animaniacs and
stuff like that inspiring this next
generation but the generation that's
coming right after x-men and Batman
stuff grew up with stuff like
transformers and so Everest before that
like Speed Racer you know it's done in
the 70s so when they were starting to
take over it's like I'm sure they're
influenced by the other stuff but then
like whatever producers are marketing
whatever saying try this and then they
didn't know how to work within the
environment which I'm not saying that's
easy you know but so they were going in
kind of with you know just trying to get
kids what they like and they're dying
off and you know the fan so let's try
these you know once it's a chart say
let's do Space Jam Michael joins popular
somebody's pocket let's do that but then
the generation after that grew up with
those shows like x-men and value-add and
I mean yeah I know the element making
these great shows now so well I'm going
on board that but think about this now
the irony is I think we've gone full
circle because our generation which I
think is in charge of half the stuff
that's coming out now our generation was
also influenced by the stuff that came
out in the 80s and if you look at
something like Steven universe which
means-- has like a 70s 80s vibe to it if
you look at something like adventure
time and I think the animation is great
but there's a simplicity to it
almost like a very crisp clean gorgeous
Anna Barbera simplicity to the animation
and a lot of these shows that are
running on Cartoon Network and stuff
it's kind of funny like we went full
circle and then you have something high
quality that like you know Cora to me
would be more like Batman the Animated
Series was does or gargoyles you know
well I and I was so brilliant about that
now a lot of you shows like gravity
falls and Adventure Time and stuff and
it's even you ever think they have money
now because they're big hit they're
starting off having those simple designs
but putting more focus in like kind of a
color and the stories and the characters
and the voice acting but having these
simple designs are not you know what is
not very strong yeah it's a stylistic
choice but but it always is money
yeah well it's funny because it reminds
me of some of the stuff we grew up with
as little kids like ones but yeah like
the old hanna-barbera stuff for the
laff-a-lympics you know but it it's so
much cleaner and Chris I mean you can
tell there's actual money behind it
literally a stylistic choice well but it
I think there is also saving like on set
you know it's like some shortcuts with
that too oh I agree you know cuz it's
like hey if we can draw these characters
really and easily agree but you'll go at
something like the cartoons we grew up
with where you know you can see the
sketch lines you can they're their
mistakes left and right I mean someone
is cuz everything's gone to digital now
so but when you look at the difference
between the grittiness of what we grew
up with versus what you have now I mean
what you've got now even when they're
saving money is still a thousand times
cleaner crisper and one and what's we
ever had growing up what's so funny
though is that I think back then they
had to design you because they were
coming off of like Bugs Bunny and Mickey
Mouse and so so when they're doing you
know and even Tom and Jerry so well
they're doing something like Jetsons or
Flintstones are these shows they're
trying to save money by cutting corners
and back then very cleverly but they
still had to have really good designs
and those designs take a while to draw
you know and it's still for a lot of
people it's hard to draw you know Fred
Flintstone but you know unless you're an
artist thin anyone can drop in like a
2.2 smut you draw a happy face and then
a little panda thing right like that's a
you've got fin so it's very clever
because it just shows this is a way to
work around it to dance around it but
also get this great artistic style
through other means kinda like what
anime does when they get the close-ups
of the eyes of the person talking the
reason that it stylistically looks great
but they're doing so they don't to
animate them outright and save on
animation a yes but they can put it in
the fight scenes and the backgrounds and
stuff so it's very very clever um we
could go on all day
yeah just guys like fucking time right
so sorry it gets us talking about TV
animations I know what was your favorite
show parrot show are we coming gargoyles
didn't Garland's is part of it oh yeah
go I mean if we're if I'm thinking
objectively what was the best probably
gargoyles my favorite though it's hard
yeah they all had their D'Argo's is
probably see for me in terms of what is
actually the best like best well done
for what they are into toss-up between
Voyles and ducktales for me because they
both delivered just perfectly and beyond
ducktales is good I loved what they were
probably oh let's go favorite era
I'm gonna go ducktales gargoyles um then
hold that I'll tell you this there was a
there was a lineup and it was there was
a lineup for a while and I think it was
gummi bears still on that lineup I know
I'm gonna say was ducktales Rescue
Rangers uh Darkwing Duck Oh and tail
spit that light up of those four yeah
that was my absolute hands-down favorite
lineup oh my gosh I couldn't miss Anna
yeah I could not miss any of those four
eventually goof troop entered and I
could miss goofed for Betty Dan be okay
I didn't hate it but it wasn't like I
have to Janice I I wasn't flipping out
if I miss it but I noticed any of those
original four holy shit yeah you know
gummy bears was good but I'm not like oh
my god I have to see gummy bears yeah
but those four yeah those are the four
I'm like I I gotta see and they always
hit the little on the next episode it's
a new if the news interrupted I'm like I
care about fucking invading Iraq
give me time Smith yeah that's what
gives an example this all happened the
news there would be breaking news
everyone's well in the middle of the
Disney Afternoon I'd be like oh we're
bombing Baghdad who cares he titled
white American kids but nobody were you
terrible people that the cat gives a
reason uh you know your talk about the
whole goof troop thing and why like I
said you kind of see why you just won't
be as invested cuz they have a little
previews you today I'm the Disney
Afternoon you know blue has to get out
of the you know these air pirates and
stuff fighting John Cunard yeah and then
Dale is gonna fall into this trap can
ship save them in time and and the
racing Rangers join a call account yeah
you know there's all stuff you know job
tales they find a lost city of gold
I'm goof troop max has to take a test
you know and even though they were
usually done fine no problem it so you
kind of see why you know man in that to
me that was the start of it because
that's when that's when the 90s crept
into the Disney Afternoon and it was no
longer this innocent timeless thing that
is when I met Kyle we get it feel to the
kids can wear the name easy we're
extreme and I like it and it's not the
worst by any stretch of imagination but
it's bits where it started that's where
it started started there and then lexing
you know we can fucking crack pack
damnit um say ah I think there's any
other stuff to say about I mean it's
pretty it's pretty obvious its influence
and you know that still holds up even
though like I said it's it doesn't hold
up like something like Batman or
Animaniacs holds up I mean those I could
just I show my wife banished she's not
into really animation or anything and I
just showed her one episode she's like
oh okay other others I'm like yeah but
not another one and soon every night we
were watching a Batman episode like you
know she could just watch it at any time
uh we're with something like rescue
rangers and stuff it's good and it's
innocent and and I could watch also
definitely like you know still for a
little kid I would watch the episodes I
remember most yeah but but it's still so
well done for little kids but it's not
hitting the adults as much but there's
still some tremors in fact it's meant
for like a very particular age range
yeah once a once you get paid so yeah
what everybody it's not they're not
aiming at you whereas BAM and always
felt like they were aiming at that
teenage crowd um but yeah it's still
it's so good I wouldn't watch all of
them like I'm not going to go out and
buy all of them on DVD like but it's the
sort of thing that like if I could pick
some of my favorite episodes and have
those on disc I told me yeah like I when
I got the DVD of Darkwing Duncan's watch
him like you know I even though some
awkward moments it's like I this still
really holds up and I really like these
characters and a lot of real Indies
again let me watch us again Oh some up
to they I felt like they was all the
same fucking universe did you get there
maybe not Rescue Rangers but I me not
telling stairway across so clearly
ducktales
darkling done and tailspin I think all
occupy the same you know tailspin was
like
like wasn't the 20s or something like
see I never knew if it was supposed to
be kind of like a timeless thing like
how Gotham City and Tim Burton's Batman
that's what they did that is 1989 but it
also anyway asking or anything it was
like mostly radios
I would like to argue it's all the same
universe
now gummy bears not so much yeah
gargoyles not so much gargoyle that's uh
but yeah I like rescue rangers from
probably not because I think aren't they
just in the human world and Rescue
Rangers yeah pretty much yeah so but but
I definitely think we might just picks
our theory and every I made from the
fact I definitely think that duck tales
darkwing duck and tailspin in mind maybe
tales from them but in my opinion that
operates all in the same evil definitely
Duncan that's clearly a spin up duck
tales clearly does yeah you have gizmo
duck and launch pad in that actually
this brings up a question does that mean
goof troop is in the same universe is
darkwing duck that made I do you know
like I'll even say reimburses quack pack
it's the NX a scenario I mean on classic
Disney characters so wait a second in
quack pad does that mean Donald just had
three new nephews Nathan the same or
like are these just to say there are
their parents you know what did his
nephews just go through an asshole stage
like is that did they go through the
home improvement kids stage I'm still
wondering what did Guffey's wife looks
like and what she died off I guess dogs
do died at a very young age in dog years
also who would date goofy who would fuck
over
oh so somebody had to do it alright so
speaking of which gadget DNA what
defy any order Hey when would you chip
that no but I would do it if you nail
that okay I feel that right in the
Monterey Jack data do my zipper you and
Hale in her Monterey Jack even different
ill in the Monterey Jack Wow and I would
be an ayat I think we covered everything
I you know she Billy that hey I'm a
she's a mouse she's a fucking Mouse well
suspension of disbelief I would assume
that you're also of similar mouths eyes
knowing you that's probably case go
ahead out there was a I will sex
I always make fun of people they're like
you know like Britney poopy I always
make fun of people like that but there
was got to look at those guys and you
know know what no but there was I know
the firm belief it just a different talk
different different storage know just
different striving for different folks i
fistful furry whatever I you know I
remember I have no problem no no but I
won't say there was a cosplayer
somewhere unlike big surprise devianart
somewhere there's like this really great
photo of like this woman who cosplaying
is like a giant was pretty much like
just herself except like me I don't even
know she did like the nose they but she
just had this hair like these fake ears
is that she looked good felt like it was
a really good cosplay uh so it's like em
it'd be there is a way to he'll be drawn
and stuff like that that's obviously try
to humanize him but no sorry I was still
thinking of sex again just as well so
anyway I'll talk about sexy gadget plus
an actual human hi
well you're still on sexting a yes I
know if we want to go down this road
tonight orange is gonna have a bunch of
people who are gonna like either be
upset or be too enthused
but be upset because we said to this
never see that saying it's never middle
of the road
it's always this one's a friend of mine
how dare you or it's just like oh my god
text me your number oh I have pictures
uh but no you know I saw the like Tina
from Bob's Burgers hey oh my god good
talk I would be in today Oh actually I
think she is I'm pretty sure in a minute
so yeah so uh maybe well I know she's a
brony and released in the context of
that show so you know what she's into oh
and zombies is that a Zuri what do you
call a zombie zone abrazo be as honest
Oh example whatever get get size of
people I know exactly what they're
called sir Oh dare you I'm insulted no
seriously you should text me your number
already had I was wrong B we're growing
group that's gotta be somebody must have
done it no loving nominees or something
like that we're really getting teary
okay whatever you guys are into more
power to it just fits him is this the
one who's all going up I have fun just
you don't need to share it with me I'm
good if you're gonna share it with me
expect comedy that's my forgot shit like
look look you can share with me all you
want but I'm gonna make fun it's just
how it's gotta be
um but uh WWE FEMA gadget - can you get
your goofy move trip there to give the
goofy gadget shipping.we holy shit oh my
god I really sighing - you're edgy how
could we take a shake Daffy how do we
take something so beautiful and innocent
like the Disney Afternoon images because
that's what quack packed it ended there
boom